the committee makes it absolutely clear
that he has been in such contempt of
parliament by doing this
that they would have recommended pretty
much the toughest sanction they could
possibly recommend and then after that
he he when he started behaving like a
child throwing his toys at the pram last
Friday
um he can he committed another contempt
of parliament by just storming off
because he refused to face the music in
Parliament and he refused to face the
music in his constituency he's a
disgraced prime minister former prime
minister
lib Dems is saying he shouldn't be
receiving the 115 000 pounds a year or
thereabouts that he's entitled to as a
former prime minister to staff his
office and the like I think we should
strip him of everything